there were some gorillas lifting weights
in the gym
then three more gorillas came and
started running
now
17 gorillas are in the gym
how many gorillas were lifting weights
so that's the number of gorillas that
were originally in the gym the gorillas
lifting weights so how many gorillas
were lifting weights and they have this
diagram for us what is this diagram
telling us how many squares are there
there's one two three four five six 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 squares so
this 17 this is how many gorillas there
are now in the gym
so this is the 17 right over here how
many gorillas how many gorillas there
are now in the gym
how many gorillas there are now in the
gym that's the 17.
now there were some gorillas in the gym
three more came and started running so
maybe these are the three that came in
and started running so one
two
three
so how many were there to begin with how
many there were there lifting weights so
all the rest of these must have been
their lifting weights so that is
1 2 3
4 5 6
7 8 9 10
11 12
13 14. so 14 gorillas we're lifting
weights that's the ones where i wrote
the numbers in this in this purplish
color then three more came came in and
started running and now there are 17 and
you see the 17 blocks how many gorillas
were lifting weights to begin with well
that's the 14.
that
is that is the 14. and there's other
ways that you could have done this you
could have said okay there were some
number of gorillas that were lifting
weights in the gym
now three more gorillas walk in
three more gorillas walk in and now
they're going to be
they're now going to be
17 gorillas so you could say okay
something plus 3 is 17
or you could say 17
minus 3
minus the 3 that walked in well that's
going to hap give you how many you
originally had
how many you originally had and either
way you think about it you're gonna get
two
you are going to get to 14. 17 minus 3
you could view that as well
this 17 is 110 and seven ones so you
take away three ones seven minus three
is four so 17 minus three is going to be
14.
let's do another one of these and this
is more of what you might see on khan
academy and it's good to just know what
they're asking for
so this says i bought a bag
of 13 mini chocolate chip cookies
my sister ate some of them and i was
left with 8 cookies
and i was left with eight cookies
how many cookies did my sister eat
so i had a bag of 13 cookies i had a bag
of 13 cookies my sister ate some of them
so those cookies are going away so i'm
going to subtract those cookies
so my sister ate some of them so that's
the question mark how many cookies did
my sister eat
she ate some of them and then i was left
with eight cookies and then i was left
with
eight cookies so 13 minus something is
equal to 8 or you could view this as if
you want to solve for the something you
could say that 13 and you some of you
might just say okay i know 13 minus 5 is
equal to 8 so you know that the question
mark is equal to 5
or you could say that 13
13 minus 8
minus 8
is equal to question mark
is equal to question mark
or you could even say well if i was left
with eight cookies
you could say if i was left with eight
cookies and my sister ate some of them
so this is what i left with plus the
ones that my sister ate that must be how
many cookies i originally had that must
be the number of cookies i originally
had so any way you do it you get your
question mark is equal to five sister
eight five cookies now they ask us which
choices can help you solve the problem
well
all of these this is so now we know the
question mark is 5 we know that 13 minus
5 is equal to 8. so let me write that
down we know that
actually let me just replace this let me
just replace this with a 5. so 13 minus
5 is equal to 8 well that's a true
statement that's describing what just
happened here so this could help me
actually not that one that's 13 plus 5.
13 minus 5 equaling 8 that's this right
over here and that is a useful thing to
know because look if i started with 13
cookies my sister ate five of them i'd
be left with eight
now what about this one over here 13
minus eight well we know this would be
equal to five now but they don't have a
thirteen minus eight equals five so we
don't have to select that
and then here we now know the question
mark is 5. so 8 plus 5 is 13. 8 plus 5
is 13 that's useful too because we know
8 plus 5 is 13 then we know what i'm
left with plus what my sister 8 is 5 is
going to be the 13 that i started with
13 plus 5 equals 18 not so useful 18 has
nothing to do with the problem there
weren't you know somehow it's not like
my my sister somehow baked five more
cookies and added them and now i'm left
with 18 cookies i'm left with eight
cookies now and so i didn't add the five
she ate those cookies
so i would subtract them